.
T ALTH NEEDSO THAT MUCH
WELCOME, SEEING HER BACK I
TIG
COMPETITION IN
HESTIF
FOR THE U.S.STTHIS MONTHT STEP
THES GAMES.
MORE NOW FROM CNN'S CAROLY
DESCRIBE
LFIDENT.
r: FLYING HIGH AFTER
RIO,NDECEDENTED
I WAH S  SHE'S E S
T
SO AMAZING.
>> Reporter: SIMONS' LIFE UN DEA
BYAL ABU
E TEAM DOCTO
NASSAR.
BILES WENT PUBY  2 TWEETING IN
ATH KNOWRRE
AT THE 202O GA THE
WORLD
SUPERMCEENOUTSIDE OF
SUFFERT SHE  THE EXPLICABLY LOSE
>> TRA SAWININING, I
OULDN'
I WAS GEINT INHE
ERSTAR
ROM EV
OVER H MEDAL COU. >> TO BRG E TA
HE, I THINK, ISH BE  A LOT ITH
G THROUGH THE SAMENG'RE ALWAYS S
>> Reporter: AFTER RETURNING
HOME FROM TOKYO AN
D SENATE YODIS HANDLING OF  NAS
BE CLE IME
ENTIRE
SYSTEM
THAT ENABLED AND PERABUSE.
>> BILE BEEN IN THERAPY WEEKLY .
SHE CONTINUES TO BE.WARE O
NOJUST EER E HIS BEHIND THE SNE.
ME AND.A
TO CAN CHANGED
AND EVOLVED >> PAMELA, I'M TTHA
FOUR ES
SATUHYDRATION EVENT
OUT FOR
EVER SINCE TNEWS BROKE THAT
SHE WOULD BE COMING BACK TO THE
SPORT AND HER RETURN TO ELITE
COMPETITION IS ALSO WIDELY
VIEWED AS RST STEP TOWARDS POTE
PARIS IN THERF 2024.
YOU SO.
SPORTSCASTER ANDING
OB COS BOB?
AND WHATL  WATCHIN
THERE'S RELYSPUTE.THLETES ESTAH
POISTORICALLY
MPETED IN
ANR OLYMPICS.
ID IN RIO IN 2016 E AGE OF 19.
NOT JUST WINNING THE EVENTS,
BUEXECINAT
TRY LET ALONE DO HALF  WELL.
E S ES
.
EN WE TALK ABOUTHE
OVPPS.SO CONNES ENTAL
THE ROM LARRY
NASSER.
THERE IS ALL THE PRESSURE  HS L
AND OTHERS.
PICS ACTATIONS ANDHEN
DISCONNECT THAT MAY AY NOT
AFFECTED BY MENTAL SS.
BUNDS TO REASON  IT
R JUST TOO NGEROUS  IT
EN YOU HAVE THATECCOULD SUSTAIN.
TO ALL THOSE THINGS CAMEPLAY AT.
ASSUMING CLI FAMRE IS O IT
SOMETHING  HERE PAMELATOKYO AS T
CS ÃÃBUT WE KNOW IT
O D IN LARGEE COVID AND
THE IOC G,  WERE ALSO
SECOND TIME MAN FOR
ICS WAS NOT ERE IS A CHANCE
OLYMPICS TO THACK.
BICKN  FAMONG E REASONS WILL BE
AND AS WE ÃSINCE E
BIOFEAK FROM COMTIVIDUAL CIRCUM
DIFFERENT.INK SHE EDTIME
AYR THAT INOT  ITOUCE A WHILE,U
PRETTY WELL SINCHOSTEDOLYMPICS
ER.
SHE'S A VERY BRIGHT UN
THAT THIS IS
CLEARLY THE LA
2NE YAT IS NOT SUCH AN  FAMOUSI
DOG.'S PRETTY CLEAR THAT SHEED .
EVERY RESPECT.
MA A YEAR FROM NOW IN
>> YES, SHE JUST HAD SO MUCH E ?
AND SHEÃME BACKLASH FOR HER
PUTTING HER SAFEHEALTH FIRST.
HOW AMONGST THIS GENERAT
ES?
CANDID ABOUT HIS GGLES WITH DE
LOWEN
OR NAOMI A SOCIS PLAYER.
TOERE ISS ST